- Governor Newsom.
His ex-wife Jennifer Newsom,
Jennifer Siebel Newsom, I
think that is her name, yes.
She called me and she
set up a meeting with me
to meet her somewhere in Brentwood,
and I actually went and I
got very like creeped out,
and I saw her sitting where
I was supposed to meet her
and I looked at her and I turned around
and went back into my car and drove away.
She wanted to meet me.
She reached out to me.
- Wait, when is this? When
is this, just to be clear?
- This is about six months
before the New York Times article
on Weinstein that I set up broke.
- Okay.
- And she called me on behalf
of a Theranos board member,
the lawyer for, long-time
lawyer of Hillary and Bill
and Clinton and Weinstein,
one David Boies.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is a New York Times bestselling author,
a global activist and a
destroyer of bad people.
Rose McGowan, finally,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Finally, Dave Rubin,
and so we meet. Hello.
- Destroyer, destroyer of bad people,
I felt that sort of captured your essence.
How do you feel about that?
- I think it's right on target.
There was somebody right after,
'cause I started going
after Governor Cuomo
about last January, right away,
on behalf of Lindsey Boylan,
and someone on Twitter
the day he resigned,
he wrote, someone wrote
on Twitter, a woman,
"God help you if Rose
McGowan comes after you."
And I'm like, "Finally,
someone recognizes me."
(Dave laughing)
Christ, how many times do I
have to tell these people,
like, I mean what I say?
- You have seriously
destroyed some people,
some pretty awful people,
and we'll get to some of that stuff
and I wanna talk about some
new stuff with you too,
but I've just learned something about you
in the last couple days
that we've been chatting,
that you're a Larry Elder gal.
- Weird.
- And I'm a Larry Elder guy
and here we are-
- And here we are.
- So talk to me.
- Yeah, I was that weird,
I don't know if I might
have been the only performer
in California ever under
contract to Paramount Studios
or Viacom that would leave set
and listen to AM 640, Larry Elder.
After that, it would be John and Ken.
Sometimes, if I got really riled up,
I would pull over on the way home.
I always used the name Tracy.
I tried to find the most
basic name I could find
'cause my voice was somewhat recognizable,
so it's like, Rose, obviously, that's,
and I would literally call and go off
on the Teacher's Union of California or LA
or like, the vice, you know,
why is the State Legislature-
- [Dave] Oh my God.
- One full calendar year
because it used to only be
six months for the State Legislature
that they got paid and then they're like,
"Well, we can achieve more if
you pay us for a whole year."
But yeah, you only work
for six months, if.
So yeah, Larry Elder.
- Wait, so you actually used a fake name
and were calling in to Larry's
Elder's show over the years?
- Yes.
- And were you, I mean, I
don't consider you Conservative
and I know the labels
all sorta mean nothing,
and especially for someone like you,
the idea of putting you
in a box is kinda nuts,
but like, do you, I mean,
do you sorta consider
yourself Conservative now
or Libertarianish or...
- No.
- Like what?
- Smart, intelligent,
like not dumb and logical.
- All right.
- Nobody seems to like to listen to that.
Labels to me, I mean, if you
flip things all the time,
like, the other night
someone was yelling at me
and they're like, "Oh,
I'm trying to sleep."
And I was like,
"Congratulations, I am
trying to stay awake."
(Dave laughing)
Or, you know, I like
flipping the language.
So like, literally, the
etymology of language
is something that fascinates me.
So, if we took Conservative
and if you take the word Liberal,
both now have like a,
because they've been slimed
and smeared and weaponized, right?
Aggressively weaponized against each other
and against humans all over the world.
But if you look at the definition of both,
they're quite beautiful.
And both are valid and both can co-exist.
So like, you know,
libservative, I don't know.
I don't know.
(laughing)
That's not pretty, I'll come
up with something better,
but I really think just
by taking the power
out of what something
traditionally means, I mean,
it was all invented at one point anyway.
- Well, you know, that Jordan Peterson guy
that I toured with was
always talking about
that healthy tension between
Conservative and Liberal,
that that's what you want
if you're gonna be in a sane society.
- I don't know about a sane society,
because I think that's still very limited.
I think like there's only
two options at that point.
If you have only two options ever
and there's no other choice, I mean,
I think the biggest thing that, you know,
I would like to run on if
I ever run for anything,
if they can make it so I
don't have to live in the US
but can be a political
figure there, I'll do it.
- Yeah, you're not thrilled
with the US these days, huh?
- I guess that's (indistinct).
We'll put a pin in that
and we'll go back to it.
(Dave laughing)
But the thing is just like
the largest voting block
I'm pretty sure is the non-voter.
Who's representing them?
Maybe me.
- Rose McGowan for the
non-voter from another country.
I like it.
- Yeah, I have a podcast I'm doing,
I've recorded four episodes so far.
Definitely not normal,
I guess according to podcast standards.
The first one, the engineer's
like, "Okay, begin."
And I'm like, "Fuck, what now? Ooh."
And I smoke a bowl,
I take a toke into the microphone, exhale,
and then just freeform and
who knows what comes out,
but it weirdly works I think.
So one of the episodes is about
the fact that we are constantly
talking about the voters
in the media, in the U S
especially and all over,
but the people that are not the voters,
so why aren't we talking to them?
Why aren't we analyzing that?
We know why, because they're
only given two choices
and it's clearly not working.
And as many alcoholics who go to AA know,
the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing
and expecting different results.
- Yeah, we're quite good at
that in the United States.
Let's back up though for a
second to this Elder situation
'cause I'm pretty amazed
that you are calling in
like I can just sort of
picture you on Mulholland,
calling in-
- The nerd in the Panamera.
(Dave laughing)
- Like they got to go into the archives
and find some of these things.
But it's not just that you like Larry
and you like what's going
on with his campaign
and we got a couple of days left
to save this freaking state.
You really do not like
Gavin Newsom, right?
- No, I do not like Gavin Newsom.
I do like Gavin Newsom at all.
- Take it away.
- In fact, I think
I would submit that single
parents in California
get less money for food
from the government
than he spends on his daily
moisturizing treatments.
And I think that goes, you know,
that sounds like ah, a
little zinger, but no,
it really goes to show what
these people prioritize.
Okay. Who they really are.
I was in California when
he was lieutenant governor.
I've been there, I was
living there for a long time
when he was like desperately
trying to be governor.
And it's like, dude,
you look like Guido Jr from a movie.
What are you doing?
Like, you're not the man and you're a lie.
- Well, he looks like the
guy from "American Psycho."
He's the guy, he's Christian
Bale in "American Psycho."
- I'm fairly sure that he
did like a deep fake AI
where he stuck his face
on Christian Bale's
in the shower scene and probably
also masturbates to that
on a loop, just saying.
Can you say that on your show?
- You can say that on my
show, we have no rules here.
- Cool.
So it's not so much
that I love Larry Elder
'cause some things I, you know,
no, like there's, you know,
certain things that I'm
not as Conservative on,
or I don't even like
that word, like I said,
but or square, square, okay, square.
I'm a little bit more like I like weirdos.
I like tiny adventures.
I like seeing where the night goes. Hey!
But I also like his mind.
I like his dedication.
I love his passion.
I love the fact that he is a true patriot.
What we need is patriots.
What we need are patriots.
I am a patriot. You are a patriot.
Anybody can be a patriot.
The non-voter can be a patriot.
Gavin Newsom, not a patriot.
There.
Now you see, when I flash anger,
people always think I'm
like that all the time.
It's like a thunder cloud
and then I'm back to me.
But I had to get out.
- Yeah and that was hopeful, not anger.
- Thank you.
That's what I think.
People always say angry
and I'm like passionate
and I feel like I am like the cheerleader,
like come on, we can do this, people.
We've got this, rise up!
You know what's been happening to you.
You know what the truth is.
Stop suspecting it and go into
the fact that it is a fact.
Okay, let's operate from a
point of fact at this point.
I get so many people,
especially American media
likes to do this to me.
So you feel this way?
No, I didn't tell you how I felt about it.
I told you today the sky
was blue in Los Angeles.
I did not tell you, wow. I
feel really great or horrible
that the sky was blue.
The sky is blue.
So it's like gaslighting
and they do it individually.
And cult members, cult
structural societies,
what they mistake is that
they, you know, in the movies,
and I grew up in one, I would know,
I have like a PhD in that,
but how I diagnose it in the US is,
I'll take that as my test model,
is that where they always get
it wrong in films, literature,
this and that is that it's
portrayed as like this Svengali
where everyone's just kind of nodding
and then goes about in
their drone-like way.
It's not quite like that.
There is the authoritarian,
but then it's up to every single member
of every single micro or macro
to cross hypnotize at all times.
And if one person, say me,
say you, say Larry Elder,
say the punk weirdo
that's like yelling truth
from under a bridge, whoever you listen to
stands up and is like,
"No, we're not having this.
You know what is true."
And you just say it and
you take it on the chin
for saying it.
I've certainly taken it on the chin,
like in every other part of my body,
like don't say, I'm like,
"But you all know it!"
And what my enemies and
your enemies, I'm guessing,
fundamentally don't
understand are my motivations,
maybe yours.
I have no skin in this game
other than the fact that I can.
Other than the fact
that I worked my ass off
to stay just relevant enough
worldwide as an actress
so I could life hack their system.
So I could gain access to
their cameras and microphones
and I could fuck them in
the ass with no lubrication.
Here I am, nice to meet you, Dave.
And now you know.
- But Rose, on Twitter it
often says, "Some people say"
or "Experts say," doesn't that mean
we're supposed to always
follow that information?
- That would be Bob in the
coffee room so some people,
some people could be, you
know, my imaginary friend,
like some people get
away with a lot of stuff.
Some people is also like,
so you feel this way, huh?
While they look at you.
- Mm-hmm.
- Like the only way we're
gonna grow and get better
is if like, call it what it is, you know?
It's like I've done it and the
world has tried to kill me.
Yes. I almost said si,
because I live in Mexico.
But you know, it is really I
think incumbent on all of us to
just, we don't have time,
we're running out of time.
So like on that interview on "Nightline,"
the last thing she said,
and it was like a warning
in this journalist's eyes.
She leans into me.
These are very powerful
people you're talking about.
And I look at her and I pause,
don't underestimate the
effect of a good pause, Dave.
And I say, "I know.
So am I."
And I took that from an army slogan,
weirdly, that I started thinking about.
Do you remember back in the
day when they changed it
from "Be all you can be,"
which is, you know, a great
tagline, a great slogan.
"Army, be all you can be."
And then they changed
it to "An army of one."
I was like,
eh, that doesn't, not
quite as catchy, right?
Eh.
But then I started breaking it down
and I was like, I started
thinking about it.
And it was about eight years before
I set up the articles to expose Weinstein.
And I started thinking about it.
I'm like an army of one.
Well, I can be an army
and I can say I'm an army.
So I started just hashtagging rosearmy.
I had no army, but I do like the Spartans
and I really liked their Trojan
horse idea. (clicks tongue)
So then I had to sound
like I was coming with
all sorts of backup.
And of course it was portrayed
as she's coming after men.
And I'm like (sighs)
believe me, there's so many women
that support this
structure that, you know,
like let's take the new governor.
Everyone was like, "The first
female governor of New York."
She was there so she knew stuff too.
You know?
- Mm-hmm.
- So a cult takes everybody to support it.
It takes a cross hypnosis
and it takes a gaslighting.
But the thing is what's great
about you, your viewers,
your people that think
differently, that look at it,
just take your lenses and
go a little bit abstract,
a little bit above and look
down and dissect the situation
and your truth, even if it's
just you, that knows it,
that is enough.
That is enough for you
to be an army of one
and an army of one can then
tagline with other armies,
other armies and we can
become a massive force
and I think that's beautiful.
- So that being said, as
someone that has, you know,
had the machine try to destroy
them over and over again,
and who took down the most
powerful people in Hollywood,
I mean, Weinstein specifically,
what do you think it is about you?
Like you specifically that
like allows you to do it
and keep going because
everyone that I talk to
wherever I go, they're always like,
"Oh, I want to speak up
more, but I have a job"
or, "Oh, I want to speak
up more, but I have kids"
or all of the things that
are legit reasons, right?
They're legit at some level.
And then on the other hand, you know,
they know they have something inside them
that they're holding
back that's feeding it.
I mean, that's the sort of hypnosis
that you're talking about.
- The big difference honestly
is that I was not raised
like you or pretty much
anybody else on this planet.
And at first people get like,
take a little umbrage at that.
"I'm unique too," yes, you are.
Yes you are. Yes you are. Absolutely.
But if you look at me
like kind of a feral child
that was born and raised in the woods
with no real contact
with the outside world,
except for very select people
that raised all the
children to be super minds,
what would happen to these children
if they didn't know the outside world,
if we did not use their language,
if we did not expose them
to really drilling home
they're a boy or a girl
or a race or an anything,
they were just minds?
That's me and then overnight,
you know, got broken up, the organization,
the group I was in that my
father was the leader of,
and I got thrown out into
Gig Harbor, Washington
and to a really unattractive
military base school.
Boom, boom.
And in my language, in my birth language,
English is my third language.
And my first, which very few people,
other than people in the children of God,
know and speak or spoke.
Everybody that was not us were systemites.
- Wait, what is the language?
- It's invented, but so is yours.
- No, but what's it called?
- It doesn't have a name.
I don't know the name.
It was just what we spoke.
And so our word for
everybody outside our walls,
we called everybody systemites.
And they're not wrong, that's the thing.
The problem with most cults
and why they don't succeed
and why an American cult as
a total cult cannot succeed
or any nation cult can not
succeed, both micro and macro,
is because they're formed I think in a way
that really negatively impacts,
the reason those people
you're talking about,
why they can't get there,
not just kids or jobs.
And yes, you have to
be pretty much selfless
and willing to take the hits.
But also I was not notified
at age three or four
that I was a girl and
here's what you can't do.
We're gonna tie your
hands behind your back
with politeness, little girl,
and we're gonna train you.
So it's around age two, three,
go sit on your uncle's lap,
give him a kiss.
You don't want to?
No, give him a kiss.
Think about it.
Then the boys, you get
put in straight jackets.
Around two, three.
Have fun getting out of that
for the rest of your life.
So your life, the systemites,
everybody that was not us essentially.
And the reason why we didn't succeed,
the cult I was in that my
father led did not succeed
is because he came from
the systemite world.
I did not.
So for me, I have no skin in
this game and all the skin.
I'm going for broke because
I can, because why not?
And I was a weird kid. Sure.
I had like Venn diagrams of
like Napoleon's battle plans
on my wall with pins.
Alexander The Great.
But then I'd read like one,
I'd read like his writings
like Napoleon or something,
and then I'd read like
five biographies on that,
like that particular battle.
And I would just like fare
it out what the truth was.
For me I was always
trying to find the truth,
but I just like strategy,
and one of the great ways that I succeed,
I've made no money from my
success in terms of, you know,
slaying the giant hydra
that is the hell scape we're living in.
I'm like, "Stay down."
(breath whooshing)
You know? I need backup.
And I'm like...
But I slay dragons.
Why? What else am I doing?
At the end of my podcast,
which is called "The Cultural Reset,"
it's gonna be on Substack,
I end it with "Why? Why the fuck not?"
And you know what? Sometimes it's fun.
You have fun, right?
Sometimes we have fun.
And people like, when I
called Oprah a lizard,
you know, which I believe is true.
I've always felt that way.
When I saw her first
on TV when I was small,
when I came to the states, I
had never seen a television.
I didn't know who she was,
but I saw her interviewing somebody
that was in an immense amount of pain.
And her eyes were like
not connected at all
but the words coming out
of her mouth were very soft
and soothing, but nothing
in the eyes connected.
And I was like (inhales
deeply), I actually was, sorry.
My ear thing is having a situation.
- [Dave] No problem, no problem.
- It's I was scared of her,
I wasn't scared of her,
but I was like (inhales deeply) like ah.
Like I've had and maybe
it is because growing up
with a father who was very
good at wiring people's minds.
He was very good at it.
Not always for nefarious reasons,
but always for ego reasons.
I don't have that ego.
I just don't.
I might seem egotistical to some,
I've certainly been called that,
but I think it's also people
are unused to people saying
what they're good at just plainly.
I also know what I'm really bad at.
I suck at quite a few things.
I'm also fucking great at
a lot of things so meh,
go from there.
- So there we are.
- There we are.
- Before we completely
lose the political part,
the Newsom part.
- Oh yeah.
It all goes together so Newsom-
- Yeah, no, it all sort of fits,
but I know you've got something
you wanted to talk about,
about Newsom specifically.
- Mm-hmm. Yes. Dave, thank
you for reminding me.
Oh, I feel like Hal 2000.
Yes. Dave.
- No, Dave. Sorry, Dave.
That's strange.
So yes, Governor Newsom,
his ex-wife Jennifer Newsom,
Jennifer Siebel Newsom, I
think that is her name, yes.
She called me and she set up
a meeting with me to meet her
somewhere in Brentwood
and I actually went.
And I got very like creeped out.
And I saw her sitting where
I was suppose to meet her
and I looked at her and I turned around
and went back into my car and drove away.
She wanted to meet me. She reached out.
- Wait, when is this, when
is this, just to be clear?
- This is about six months
before the New York Times article
on Weinstein that I set up broke.
- Okay.
- And she called me on behalf
of a Theranos board member,
the lawyer for, long time
lawyer of Hillary and Bill
and Clinton and Weinstein,
one David Boies.
So this woman, I don't know,
some blonde lady with the last
name of Newsom cold calls me.
And is like, "David Boies wants to know
what it would take to make you happy."
- Six months before the Weinstein story,
what it would take to make you happy,
which you took as?
For those that might be playing
along a little bit slowly.
- I don't know.
I don't know if it would
be fiscal remuneration.
I don't know.
Like absolutely nothing
would make me happy.
You falling off the planet,
David Boies, and your whole company.
If you all fall off the
planet, I would be happy.
Since you cannot do that, I
will remain unhappy with you
and you shall deal with my displeasure.
But they're scary. These are operators.
They're tied into SKDKnickerbocker.
They're tied into Hillary.
They're tied into Nancy Pelosi.
This is all back door
bullshit for their gain
and we're tired of it, we're suffering.
People are dying.
Not just 'cause of stupid ass COVID,
but because their fucking
system is fucking killing us
and I've had it and I
think a lot of us had.
So now it's time to go from feeling,
I feel this is all bullshit,
to fact, it is all bullshit and
vote Larry Elder 'cause why?
Why the fuck not?
What have you got to lose?
How's it going, people?
How's your systemite
society working for you?
Try something different. Might as well.
There's my pitch.
(both laughing)
- Like a pro, like a pro.
- I think I'd be like the
best campaign, like you know?
I just like, for me, like I
used to volunteer years ago
at a place called Covenant House
and I never did it with
cameras and I would go
and I would speak to
homeless runaway trans kids,
which, you know, because
I was taken in by them
when I was a homeless 13 year old.
That's who raised me, they
were like my mothers, right?
And so I always felt like
I would repay the favor.
And I knew that state run
therapy could not help them
in the way that I could,
because I don't use language
the same way most people do
and I'm not scared.
So when a kid, when the
therapist would say,
this goes together with this,
"How did that make you feel?"
And they're like, hm, they're like,
the hard shell comes up, that
doesn't make me feel anything.
And I, because I'm not bound by state laws
or regular normal ways conversing,
which is why I'm effective I believe,
is simply because I said, "Really?
That would hurt me so badly.
I would feel so betrayed and abandoned
if the person I came here with
abandoned me on the first day
and left me to rot on the streets.
That would like shake my faith in humans
and everything else."
And I feel like that is
what the state of California
needs to say to Gavin
Newsom on election day,
"You have betrayed us, you've hurt us,
you and your whole type,
because you are one in
a long line of lizards
and we don't want you anymore."
I like lizards, I like real lizards,
but I don't like the fake
lizards. (clicks tongue)
So clean house, you can
do it, go to the polls,
do it for me, 'cause I'm not gonna.
You got this.
- Just to be totally clear here,
Gavin Newsom's wife-
- Or ex wife.
- Wanted to sit down with you,
which then turned out to be
on the phone where she said,
"What can Harvey Weinstein's lawyer do
to make this story go away?"
What's the connection
to Gavin Newsom's wife?
Why was it that she was the
one that was calling you?
- Mystified me too, because
they tried every way they could.
They tried every single way
they could to get to me.
I mean, my literary agency, Dupree Miller,
who I hired to represent me,
to shepherd and protect
my book from Weinstein.
Jan Miller is a big literary firm,
and they were secretly exposed,
they were exposed for secretly
working with Weinstein
the entire time they're supposed
to be protecting my book.
They were exposed to the
New York Times for that.
And when I met her, this Jan Miller woman,
she was bragging about like
giving a $15,000 a plate dinner
for David Boies and Bill and
Hillary that night in Dallas.
So do the math, it's all connected.
It is all connected.
One at a time, I am coming.
- Yeah, I mean, that seems
like a fairly big scandal
with an election coming
in four days, basically.
- I guess in my world, it's
like Tuesday at 2:00 p.m.
- It's just like another-
- In my horror like
literally, do you remember-
- Oh, the governor's wife
calling me to, you know,
basically shut me up with money
about the biggest sex scandal of all time.
Eh.
- It's a serial rapist
and I loathe the media.
They're always like "Disgraced producer."
I'm like if he was an
indigent black rapist,
would you say disgraced,
disgraced homeless rapist?
No, he is a convicted serial rapist.
Let's just say it. We can all be adults.
It wasn't pleasant. It wasn't fun.
They really built a beast in me
and all I ever wanted to
do in my whole life, Dave,
was lay under a tree at night in the grass
and look for owls.
- I know, I know.
I know that's true of you.
You love the owls
and we've got this very
bizarre owl connection.
We both have owls hanging
outside our house.
- We'll address that in part two,
but, so I said the things.
If there are people out
there that can go in on this
and work it out and expose more,
yes, they're all part of it.
And this whole like Oprah saying like,
or Meryl Streep or Gavin Newsom,
"Oh, we were in our ivory tower.
We just didn't know anything about it.
We're too fancy for that.
That's just those, you
know, the little actresses,
they were short skirts, they deserved it."
No, this was a machine. This is a machine.
It has many, many tentacles.
One tentacle's the human
trafficking arm of it, right?
He had a daily appointment
for rape, 1:00 p.m.,
around 1:00 p.m. every day,
daily appointment for many years
anywhere there's a film festival
and it takes his protection.
I introduced Hillary at OZY Fest
about three something
years ago in Central Park
so it was like a rock
concert for speakers.
So they got me up there.
And at this point I had
just really found out
how deep involved in this whole thing,
like that camp was, right?
And that it hadn't really
been publicly outed yet
by me or anybody.
And so they said, "Okay,
so you're gonna introduced Hillary."
And I'm like, "Great, I got this."
So the last thing I said to this,
like it was like a rock concert, right?
I'm up there.
And I said, "And the last thing
I will say to you all today,
Harvey Weinstein was protected
by the Democratic Party.
Welcome to the stage, Hillary Clinton!"
And this collective (gasps)
Northern liberal gasp,
and suddenly, I was literally
like yanked off stage.
They wouldn't let me go
backstage to get my purse.
I'm walking out of Central Park.
I see her like town car go by,
I see the hair like and profile
and I just see her face
like in profile go.
And I was like (clicks tongue), nailed it.
- Wow.
- I do what I can.
I serve, why?
Because I was born to.
- Is there video of that?
I mean, oh my God, it's
gotta be somewhere.
- Maybe.
I looked for it on their site,
but of course no, you know?
They take down everything.
But somebody out there has that video.
I certainly did it.
- So what do you think
this thing is sort of?
Is it like a Hollywood protection,
not even just Hollywood,
is it just the machine protection racket?
It's sort of, we're all
sorta in it, whatever it is.
We're all protecting each other.
Every now and again we
have to sacrifice somebody
so that the masses don't fully
get what we're all doing?
Because you know, when
you're mentioning Oprah
and Meryl Streep and everything,
I know a lot of people are gonna be like,
"But I like Oprah. I like Meryl Streep."
- Yeah. I would like to like them too.
Trust me, every time I discover
someone is exactly as I suspected,
I am very like bummed out.
It doesn't make me happy.
Does not make me happy.
Gosh, if you don't think
I want someone to be real,
like please somebody be real.
Just somebody be what they say,
but the reality is I meet
bus drivers that are real.
The reality is I meet an
owner of a 711 franchise
in Detroit named Robert, he's real.
Those are the real people, right?
Not them.
And you know and I know
that the Pentagon, like CIA,
it all goes, like I believe the reason
we're not at war with Iran right now,
and people might start laughing,
is because "Top Gun 2" was
delayed because of COVID.
Now you think about that for a second.
"Top Gun 1."
No, you're gonna laugh.
- Yep.
- While I was off the grid,
I only watched one movie
basically, it was "Top Gun"
so I'm gonna really follow this with you.
- Right, so if you look
at it historically,
so after the Vietnam War,
very low military enrollment.
People saw it for what it was.
They were not into it. They're like done.
So then they're like,
"Damn, we need a war soon.
We need to rah, rah, ramp it up.
So what do we do? 'Top Gun.'"
So anytime you mention the
CIA, even in like a sitcom,
you have to say something
positive about them.
They control and approve
any use of even those
three letters, right?
Any use of anything like The
Pentagon, anything like that.
So it's tit for tat, but
it's also total directives.
And the directive is we
need to staff our restaurant
that's opening in six months to a year.
That's the directive.
It worked, "Top Gun" came out.
My little brother watched it.
He went to the Air Force Academy.
He's a fighter pilot.
He flies F-16s and F-18s.
You know, the realest texts
that ever got in my life
was from him when he was
in Afghanistan, texting me,
"I just dropped on my first target."
And now they'll ask, "Why did I do that?"
Because these people all work in concert.
On the surface,
they say that America's number
one export is Hollywood.
First of all, they're stupid.
They're not good at business.
They could be making so much more.
Because they have a terrible
work ethic and they're dodos,
they leave a lot of money on the table,
but more importantly-
- And they're making a lot of
crappy shit too at this point.
Like they're not even
faking it anymore, right?
- No.
Well, it's just like,
everyone's like, "Oh God,
they're going to kill
Epstein" and then they do.
And they're like, "Yeah, I
guess they did. All right."
Like they're not even
pretending. Right? Exactly.
But like every part of
it, it's like when Mexico
tried to get it's land back
from being stolen by the US,
who runs to Hollywood with a new
and invented word called marijuana?
Let's make it sound Latin,
Spanish, scary, Mexican.
And then they do one
minute movies in Hollywood
that they pump out, that's like 1940s,
before all the other movies,
like a Jewish guy painted
brown in a sombrero
like chasing after a white college girl
smoking the marijuana, like that.
Like this is how they do it.
And it is in concert
and it is brainwashing
and it is manipulation.
And it's all connected.
The reason there's, if
Hollywood was in fact
America's number one export,
do you think there would
be government oversight?
There is none.
There's no human resources
department for that shit hole.
And if it stayed local, if it
stayed there, that'd be great.
I wouldn't fuck with them,
I'd be like losers hangout.
But they're loser dome goes to the world
and I know the people who are
putting thought in your head,
which is why four days after
the Weinstein expose broke
I tweeted at Jeff Bezos,
one, two, three, four,
and I made my case.
By two hours later, his personal attorney
called me on my cell phone,
probably got my number
off my Amazon account,
maybe, I don't know.
And I explained what was up.
I destroyed Price, head
of the studio, why?
I was deeply offended that that stupid man
was putting thought in
your head, in my head
and everybody's head,
'cause when you sit
down to watch something,
your brain is open, you want to go away.
That is the exchange between
the screen and the audience
and what they have been
implanting in American minds,
we're the nerve center and
our stuff goes to the world.
So other people get a watered
down version of our fuckery,
and they certainly have their own fuckery,
but we are ground zero for the fuckery.
And what I see being
done to people in the US,
I just came back to the
US for the first time
in almost two years, right?
No, you don't deserve this.
You have to rise up, all of you,
because is it killing you.
It's not okay to live like this.
It's not okay to live in terror.
It's not okay to be lied to about
you're the number one person in the world
with healthcare, lie.
100% lie.
That you are the brave, lie.
You're the easiest to scare. Why?
Because they control,
they show you nothing of the outside world
other than terrorism
and natural disasters.
If the overwhelming majority of Americans
don't have passports, other
people in other countries
make fun of us for that,
but it's not fair to do that.
Why would you go outside
when everything they've ever shown you
in the news is terrifying?
Like at the BBC, corrupt of course too,
but they'll be like, "The
weather in Addis Ababa,
the weather in Jakarta," just
as sort of side segments.
So any little kid watching or anybody
has a slight consciousness
that there's a bigger world
that we can all go be a part of,
without nations, without
borders that we can visit it.
There is nothing like that
in the US and the frequency,
like the sound that they
put on your news here,
it's like bullets in your body.
And then the TVs are enormous.
They dominate.
So this stuff is like really
systematically being done.
It is thought out, it is not accidental.
It is on purpose.
The next time we talk,
I will tell you how I
finagle my way into Langley,
the CIA, Air Force Two,
the war room,
The Pentagon,
ah, Kandahar,
Kabul.
And the last note, if you
ever go to war again, America,
and I'm sure you will,
do not feed them the food
they fed me at Bhagran
before you go out to
die, that is not fair.
I'm gonna leave you on that cliffhanger.
But Larry Elder.
Fuck you, Newsom. Suck it. (clicks tongue)
- Rose McGowan, ladies and gentlemen.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about women's issues
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our women's issues playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.